that wall down
no there will not be another foot of
wall constructed in my administration
why is the biden administration building
a border wall in arizona
so um
we are not
we're not finishing the wall we are
cleaning up the mess the prior
administration
left behind in their in their failed
attempt
to build a wall
okay the binding administration tried to
defend authorizing funding to close
multiple border wall gaps in the yuma
arizona sector of our southern border
with mexico despite what you've heard
there the president's campaign trail
promised not to build another foot all
right so let's start there with the team
tonight the brim team panel to break it
down former state department official
david tafari democratic strategist kevin
walling and project 21 co-chair horace
cooper gentlemen great to have you all
back with us tonight
hey shannon
thank you okay so this is what the cbp
chief raul ortiz tweeted today he says
we're funded to close four border gaps
in yuma sector closing these gaps will
help deter migrants from crossing in
this dangerous area which this fiscal
year has accounted for 45 761
apprehensions and 45 water rescues and
horace one of our guests we've had on uh
this week said there have been a lot of
deaths this is a dangerous trek that
people go on coming here um so the wall
closing
whatever you want to call it this
administration says now's the time for
that
see this administration instead of just
agreeing to do the right thing because
it's the right thing the wall is a good
idea and it saves lives but instead we
have to redefine we're not rebuilding
the wall
we're
saving lives
inflation is just tentative it's gonna
pass it's transitory except it's now at
a 40-year high
it's not a recession that's not the
technical term for what's going on when
in fact americans are saying at levels
we've not heard since the jimmy carter
administration it's a recession it's
terrible
this administration should stop playing
the word games all right so let's take
it to kevin our democratic strategist
here
congressman andrew clyde he's a
republican from georgia tweets this
after hispanic support for president
biden craters to 26 approval he suddenly
wants to complete the border wall kevin
well shannon i really don't think
there's politics involved as you rightly
point out so many lives have been lost
including the life of a five-year-old
girl who just drowned last month at that
border crossing so there's an
appropriation of that money to to fill
in those gaps around yuma arizona we've
got to take the politics out of this
this is actually about saving lives of
these migrants so desperate to come to
this country including that little girl
who got separated from her mom so i want
to put the politics aside if we can and
actually do the right thing for the
american people which is to horse's
point build part of this wall back and
i'm a democrat that believes in border
security and increasing funding for
patrol officers and border enhancements
okay so there have been many who have
said this is a national security issue
when we're talking about what goes on at
the border but i want to talk to another
national security issue tonight and
that's dealing with china so david
you're our expert here on foreign policy
on this panel so let's talk through this
um the speaker nancy pelosi is heading
out on an asia trip and there have been
threats
that possibly her plane could be shot
out of the sky or should be by some you
know crackpot in china if she should
dare to go visit taiwan now here's
former secretary of state mike pompeo
his tweet a couple days ago he says
nancy speaker pelosi nancy i'll go with
you i'm banned in china but not freedom
loving taiwan see you there so there are
those on the right who say she should go
now the hill has this headline today
talking about former president trump it
says he slams pelosi's plan taiwan visit
she will only make it worse david what
do you think about her potential visit
this is such an interesting standoff you
know the speaker of the house has the
right to go and visit taiwan if she
wants to
the congress is a co-equal branch of
government and as the leader one of the
leaders in congress it's important for
her to go and visit our allies and
taiwan is a democratic ally china has
actually probably made it more likely
that she's going to go because if she
doesn't go now people will think that
she didn't go because china instructed
her not to and china has no right to be
instructing any u.s official whether it
be a congresswoman or someone in the
biden administration not to go and visit
taiwan and if we back down now
you know what will china do the next
time someone wants to visit taiwan their
response will be even stronger and more
threatening
i do think china may take some
provocative action i think it's very
unlikely that china would make the
mistake of endangering
the speaker of the house or doing
anything to endanger her airline flight
into taiwan well kevin what about this
because there are democrats and
republicans who are kind of flipping
sides and finding alliances about how
they feel about whether she should go or
not it's one of those weird washington
things where people are all over the
place it really is there are interesting
dynamics at play mike mccall the
republican ranking member of the foreign
affairs committee is cheering the
speaker on for this visit and we've got
to remember speaker pelosi has a long
history with taiwan and the chinese
communist regime she was in tiananmen
square protesting for human rights
bringing the fight to china so she
believes strongly in this i think she's
also seeing potentially that this might
be her last term as speaker i don't
believe it as the democrat on your panel
but i think this would be a serious
capstone for her who has believed so
strongly in advocating for human rights
that she's got to go and she's got to be
present in taiwan yeah so the white
house taking some heat from not having a
more
clear message on this issue
but another issue they got to deal with
domestically is the economy um horse you
referenced this and and this idea of
changing uh words and definitions and
that kind of thing um politico though
says this uh this is an opinion piece
that says wait is biden a better
president than people thought they're
talking about this in the context of the
economy and everything else they say
following a pattern with long roots in
his career biden is looking a little
like this student who's failing his
class for most of the semester then
pulls an all-nighter and slips the paper
under the professor's door at six am
turns out the paper is actually pretty
good there's no way he's getting an a
for the term but no fear greater would
give him an f either a solid b is within
reach horace you're great for the
president
i used to teach constitutional law i
know of this experience or attempt on
the part of students and they did not
get a b they did not get a c
they might have gotten a d class
participation and what you do for the
entirety of the term matter this
president every time he has touched a
policy whether it's energy whether it's
the economy whether it's international
relations he has made it worse and for
him to think that there's some little
clever thing that he can sort of cram in
at the last minute minute like this new
deal that he's worked out with mansion i
tell you when you look at it and you
grade it you're going to give that an f
nothing has improved i'm going to have
nightmares tonight the ones i always
have about law school about showing up
at the wrong place for my exam and
everything else um of course she would
have been great very interesting
professor i have a feeling david horace
and kevin thank you all coming back soon
thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else